the laker nation why listen why are
people so excited it's still
1-1 i know but they just want to get at
you
they just want to get me hey listen i'm
sticking with my pick hey dame
rub some icy hot on the shack right on
the uh ain't no shack right who was that
from
laker nation my laker nation okay well
if the laker nation has
a distinguished gentleman to do
something i got to do it
oh why why you got to put your mask on
got to fix it apparently he's going to
stand up
and walk away feel good america okay
yeah you're good
yeah look good we don't see your face oh
that's not even the broom if you break
that one shaq yeah i'll tell you man
that's not even
the cheap proof
hey y'all all excited y'all won a game
hey
don't you ever disrespect liquid nature
you understand me
i got you like a nation always hey hey
he broke that for real
wait y'all all sisters y'all since it's
1-1
all black people know if you put duct
tape on something it'd hold it together
yeah that's how we put our furnace
together in the hood well hey put some
duct tape on it
and you're good to go dame i need three
more wins brother
why you always switch up like that you
said the lakers are getting swept
it's still clear we know it's one to one
and now it's going to be a good sir but
your worst
actually no worries when you come to the
words
when you come out and say it's going to
be a sweep you've got to expect come on
i got your leg